Let's look at the solution for
our three protocol comparison quiz.
Where we had 3 cores, a block A that
starts in an invalid state in all
three caches, and then cores
access this block in this way.
We were asked, how many memories and
bus requests do we have in
each of these protocols?
When a read A occurs, we will have a
memory read in each of these protocols,
because this is a miss on core 1.
At that point,
C1 has the block in the shared or
exclusive state, depending on whether
the protocol has a shared state or not.
So in the MOSI,
we will have shared state.
In MESI and MOESI, we will have the
exclusive state because at this point,
C1 is the only one who
has this block at all.
When C1 writes to A,
if we had the block in the shared state,
we need to put an invalidation request
on the bus because we don't know whether
there are any other sharers.
And, of course,
if we did the memory read,
we'd also have a bus request
in each of the three.
Now when we do a write A for
protocols that have the E state,
we just move to the modified state.
We don't have to put anything
on the bus or read memory.
So here, we don't do anything, but
for MOSI we were in the shared state.
We have to put an invalidation
request on the bus.
There is no memory read here,
we already have the data
we just need to invalidate others
because we think there might be others.
So now we have the block in
the modified state in C1.
Everybody else still has
the block in the invalid state.
When C2 reads A,
C1 must supply this data.
So this is a bus request because
we have a read in all of them.
C2 will get the data in
the shared state because C1 will
be downgraded from modified
to either shared or owned.
But either way C2 will be shared.
C1 will have the block in either
the O state, if there is an O state,
because from modified we go
to O once we start sharing.
Or, in the shared state
assuming we have intervention
base supply of this value to C2,
there is no memory read.
Because C1 is able to
provide the block to C2.
Now, when C2 writes to the block,
because it has the block in the shared
state, there will be a bus request
to send out an invalidation.
Either way, C1 now has the block
in the invalid state, and
C2 has the block in the modified state.
So from this read to this write,
having the exclusive state didn't help
us save an access on a write, and
that's because here we had no
exclusive access to the block anymore.
C1 also had the block.
Now let's see what
happens when C3 reads.
When C3 reads,
C3 will get the block in the shared
state, and this is a read miss,
it needs the data, so that is
definitely a bus access in all of them.
C2 however, moves to either the owned or
the shared state,
depending on whether we
have the owned state.
In this case, again, C2 supplied the
data to C3 so there was no memory read.
However, when C1 reads,
if we are in the shared state in C2,
C1 ends up reading memory.
So if we have the O state,
C2 is able to intervene and
supply the data to C1, and then C2,
if we have the shared state,
then there are memory
accesses in both of these.
C1 had the block in the invalid state,
so
definitely the read request
will be put on the bus.
And now what we have is basically C1 and
C3 have the block in the shared state.
C2 retains the block in the owned or
shared state.
So there was a bus request here, and
there was a memory request if
we didn't have the O state.
So here we have
an additional memory read.
Now C2 reads the block.
Either way, it can read the block,
because at this point,
it's either owned or shared.
So there is no bus request, nor
memory read in any of these protocols.
So overall,
we have 1 memory read in protocols
that have the O state and
2 in the protocol that doesn't.
For bus requests,
we have 5 bus requests in protocols
that have the exclusive state and 6 bus
requests in the protocol that doesn't.